bonjour mon invité aujourd'hui est
Françoise Bourdin alors Françoise
Bourdin vous la connaissez certainement
elle a signé de nombreux romans comme
soleil mouillé ou l'héritier des
beaulieues mais si je vous dis que
Françoise Bordin est l'auteur d'une saga
qui nous a tous fait vibrer c'était en
été 96 et ça s'appelait terindigo vous
allez me dire mais bien sûr on la
connaît Françoise Bourdin c'est mon
invité aujourd'hui bonjour Françoise
alors on parlait donc de ces adaptation
de ces romans il y a eu Terre Indigo
c'était c'est ça l'été 85 le temps passe
et puis il y a eu plus récemment retour
à Fontaine c'était il y a 15 jours sur
France 2 alors dites-moi qu'est-ce que
ça fait de voir ces personnages d'un
seul coup devenir vivant réel c'est
magique c'est magique on passe de
l'autre côté du miroir c'est toujours
extraordinaire on est très souvent déçus
il faut pas se leurrer parce que bon
dans un livre en mettant de choses que
tout ne peut pas toujours être adapté
exactement la même manière tu es obligé
de faire des concessions de
décors ne correspondent pas forcément à
ce qu'on avait imaginé mais quand même
c'est magique est-ce que l'auteur a son
mot à dire alors là dans dans le cas de
cette mini-série retour à Fontaine
j'avais mon mot à dire parce que c'était
moi l'adaptateur donc j'ai fait
l'adaptation le scénario et les
dialogues donc là j'avais mon mot à dire
mais on est quand même toujours obligé
de tenir compte du cahier des charges de
ce qu'on exige pour quand même tous ces
téléspectateurs pour que ce soit facile
à comprendre les deux livres étaient
quand même très longs ça fait un énorme
pavé de 700 pages on peut pas mettre
tout ça dans de téléfilms donc on est
obligé de faire des sacrifices je les ai
fait volontiers et puis je suis contente
du résultat parce que parce que j'étais
contente des comédiens mais enfin la
plupart du temps pour répondre à votre
question l'auteur n'a pas beaucoup son
mot à dire alors par exemple sur Terre
Indigo est-ce que vous aviez choisi
Francis Huster non non pas du tout et
pas davantage sur les autres par exemple
à la rentrée toujours sur France 2 On
verra une autre adaptation de d'un
bouquin qui s'appelle les sirènes de
Saint-Malo là c'est pas moi qui ai fait
l'adaptation
euh je n'ai pas choisi les comédiens et
on a pas demandé mon avis bon c'est
c'est Jacques Perrin ça sera très bien
et comment ça se passe alors comment
est-ce qu'un jour un livre est choisi
pour être adapté à la télévision c'est
votre proposition et où est-ce qu'on
vient vous chercher non c'est rarement
la proposition de l'auteur les
producteurs qui sont tous des structures
indépendantes sont avides de livres ils
disent énormément et quand un livre leur
plaît bah à ce moment-là en général il
contacte d'abord le diffuseur la chaîne
pour savoir si ce sujet là pourrait
plaire et après il contacte l'éditeur et
l'auteur pour pour l'acquisition des
droits d'accord vous voyez moi je me
posais toutes ces questions sur ces
adaptations à la télévision mais
maintenant on a les réponses alors
Françoise vous habitez en Normandie chez
nous dans le département de l'Eure et je
sais qu'il y a un endroit je me suis
renseignée je sais qu'il y a un endroit
où vous aimez aller vous promener un
petit porte de pêche je vous propose ces
images elles sont rien que pour vous
[Musique]
c'est une promenade dans les rues et les
quartiers de ce Vieux-Port situé dans
l'estuaire de la Seine et dans ce
paradis des peintres notre guide est
moineau l'ambassadeur de la poésie et du
rêve
il y a des lieux que vous préférez en
fleurs oui la place Sainte-Catherine
givy j'y habite et puis aussi la côte de
grâce que j'aime beaucoup
[Musique]
et c'est la ville de la peinture c'est
le berceau du rêve
car ici est vivant là la poésie la
peinture la musique tout en fin de
compte un peu comme c'était avant dans à
Montmartre comme c'était avant je pense
à d'autres endroits qui se sont
extrêmement modernisés et qui ont un
petit peu
[Musique]
abandonné la part du rêve pour la part
de la rentabilité on fleur n'en est pas
là et je pense que même si des fois il
dévie un peu il est vite rattrapé parce
que il y a une magie ici il y a des
magiciens et des faits invisibles et qui
ramènent toujours en fleurs vers le bon
rivage et on retrouve toujours le bon
goût quand même on retrouve toujours à
cette tendresse et on échapotant je
crois que c'est ça définir en fleur une
ville qui a échappé autant c'est un lieu
touristique mais qu'on peut visiter tout
aussi bien l'hiver d'abord parce que
l'hiver il y a encore plus de place pour
le rêve et puis en fin de compte ce
bassin le soir quand les lumières mauves
et rouges se posent du ciel et donnent
en fleurs cette brillance magique que
boudin Gervaise et robot Hambourg ont
découvert
ces mystère qui fait que la lumière
n'est pas comme ailleurs et d'où vient
cette lumière qui le sait pourquoi le
même les gens du monde entier vient de
la saisir et c'est le venait d'une autre
dimension et qu'on sache pas ici on
fleurait tes prisonnier d'une quatrième
dimension dans laquelle on rentre et on
sort sans savoir
raison on fleure c'est magique je crois
que si un jour j'étais en panne
d'inspiration je touche du bois cette
époque arrivée mais j'irai à Honfleur
pour en trouver je suis sûr que j'en
aurai là c'est un lieu où je suis
toujours toujours allé très
régulièrement chaque fois que je suis
allée après la mort de mon père il y a
20 ans je sais pas c'est un lieu dans
lequel il se passe des choses voilà bon
c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de
touristes à Honfleur mais c'est quand
même bien préservé et le matin sur ce
petit port là sur le Vieux Bassin et là
aujourd'hui avec le temps qu'il fait ça
doit être un vrai
bonheur alors on parlait justement de
trouver les sources d'inspiration votre
dernière roman que je vous recommande
moi je l'ai lu en une journée ça
s'appelle nom de jeune fille c'est une
encore une histoire une sorte de Saga
peut-être un jour à la télévision c'est
l'histoire d'un grand patron du CHU de
Rouen c'est une fiction
euh ça se passe donc la toile de fond
c'est le CHU de Rouen alors toutes les
personnes qui ont été hospitalisées vont
reconnaître le CHU de voilà parce que
tellement bien écrit bon et une histoire
d'un couple une histoire d'amour
histoire d'un coup une histoire d'amour
et surtout l'histoire d'une femme qui va
qui va refaire sa vie qui va tout
recommencer à zéro
sujet actuel s'il en est voilà comment
faire quand on est une femme qu'on
approche quand même qu'on n'est pas très
loin de la quarantaine quand c'est
consacré beaucoup à son mari à ses
enfants qu'on a pas exercé et puis que
tout d'un coup bon on se retrouve avec à
tout reconstruire comme ça c'est pas
c'est pas simple
si vous voulez le lire mais la femme en
question elle aussi médecin oui
elle va de temps en temps il retourne
par ses parents et là aussi on reconnaît
les les moi j'ai reconnu les rues droits
les les petites boutiques les rues de
Rouen c'est vieille rue c'est vieilles
maisons qui sont tellement fascinantes
ça je m'étais juré qu'un jour un de mes
romans se déroulera dans ce cadre là
j'adore venir à Rouen je traîne dans les
rues et je me disais des personnages
c'est obligé alors justement pour
trouver vos thèmes l'inspiration vous
faites comment je fais rien je fais rien
je me promène le nez au vent et
jusqu'ici je n'ai jamais eu de soucis
tout d'un coup je veux écrire cette
histoire là voilà le lieu c'est
important mais ça vient après en général
c'est telle histoire que je veux
raconter après la toile de fond et puis
et puis après tout ce merveilleux
travail de mécano qu'elle travaille du
romancier trouver des prénoms
trouver des métiers trouver des métiers
et vous avez comme ça en réserve des
idées des thèmes de livres qui dorment
en ce moment je n'en ai pas en réserve
je n'en ai pas d'avance voilà je suis
pas très riche je n'en ai pas d'avance
mais j'en ai toujours un en train en le
prochain roman que je prépare pour pour
l'année prochaine qui est déjà bien
avancé sera dans un monde bien différent
est-ce que ce sera l'histoire d'un
musicien voilà et bien travailler
comment quand le matin c'est le matin
très tôt je suis très matinale je me
lève toujours de bonne humeur et et de
bonheur et bon je peux dire qu'à 7h j'ai
déjà ouvert mon ordinateur et voilà le
matin je trouve que c'est un bon moment
pour travailler après dans la journée je
vais me promener je vais me promener
avec mon chien dans la forêt où je
prends ma voiture j'adore conduire et là
aussi sur les routes c'est facile de
trouver l'inspiration sinon vous êtes
une femme comme nous vous allez faire
vos courses vers nous
voilà je vous avais dit qu'on allait
passer un bon moment je vous recommande
à nouveau ce je l'ai peut-être pas fait
les autres fois mais je vous le
recommande vraiment ce bouquin parce que
il est super ici en une journée c'est un
roman vraiment passionnant marrant
d'actualité et puis après tout je vous
l'offre 35-0 3 0 5 0 3 demain j'aurai un
autre invité c'est Éric Le Nabor il nous
vient de la ville de Caen et je vous dis
au revoir à demain 12h50
[Musique]